so thank you for the invitation for the
organizers lot of fun to be right after
lunch so hopefully some more food for
thought what I will try to go through is
some of the examples hopefully pressing
on or opening some questions that we can
discuss in a discussion in the afternoon
that relates to aspect that algorithms
are obviously interesting important and
essential but a lot of Lee really new
breakthrough analytical results come
from breakthrough new data that is all
the long time existing algorithms have
been applied to so one of the things
definitely for systems biology or
integrated computational biology what I
more prefer because what we try to do is
to integrate different kinds of data
different kinds of omics data imaging
data clinical data annotation data
medical records information about the
drugs their target transcriptionally
modified profiles and so on and it
obviously is represented in multiple
different ways across the globe
integration sounds simple but it's not
as simple because even simple thing is
unique identifiers obviously biology's
and clinicians didn't go to database
course 101 and they don't like unique
identifiers in general and there are all
sort of other issues that one has to
deal with before we can move to the next
level which is trying to integrate any
of these data through machine learning
data mining statistical tools and
identify what is potentially related to
some phenotypes but it's really the
cracks of understanding the biological
mechanism oh it is to linking it to
different kind of networks and networks
can be obviously metabolic protein
interactions regulatory networks drag
target networks and so on and so forth
so you can view this as multiple layers
of networks and obviously multiple
layers of this data that we are trying
to integrate and analyze obviously again
multiple machine learning data mining
approaches to identify patrons in this
and the more important aspect is to
interpret these patrons is it just
something occurring or it has a clinical
or biological meaning can we predict
something that we didn't
re only confirming what is already there
so if they're generating hypotheses and
then validating many times through
clinical models sometimes building are
really differential equations for
modeling certain signaling cascades we
can identify what percentage of
predictions were true or false there are
multiple aspects that one has to
consider and as in statistics obviously
once you have data you can find
statistical tests that will prove it
significant somebody tells you the dopes
the labels were the opposite direction
and that decision could easily reply
that and that's even easier to prove
that it's significant so one has to be
careful that what we see are is really
true obviously it was already discussed
many times today in terms of the
randomizations and proper controls and
so on but one has to also consider other
aspects in terms of the biases that we
may not even know about we talk about
certain cancers we talk about certain
histological subtypes certain great
stages mutations and so on but there are
so many things we will never know and we
cannot consider these groups to be
homogeneous by any fact there are many
unknowns also one of the interesting
thing which obviously I'm not going to
talk about but it's chronobiology and
chronobiology basically looks into what
parts of the proteome and genome are
active in what state of cell cycle and
also circadian rhythm and so when you
consider different responses patient to
chemotherapy one of the reasons could
also be that some patients are treated
in the morning at there are in the
afternoon others are and so on and so
forth so there are many variables that
can contribute to the variability of the
result that we are not even considering
there is also a lot of missing data
various approaches to impute the data
but in most of the cases you can find
situations where you take the missing
data as a special value and you can find
that the value is actually predictive so
then there might be a reason for the
missing value and you cannot ignore it
many bed platforms and so on we don't
need to go there but one of the other
aspect I hopefully we'll have time to
touch on these mistakes and so on and
kind of wood is really ground
truth today they're already discussion
where discussions about is to hybrid
mass spectrometry a curated interactions
and so on and people have their
favorites but you can find errors in
order of those so you cannot blindly
just say because it's used to hybrid is
a noisy data because sometimes mass spec
will be a lot more noisy than used to
hybrid and vice versa so one of the
thing with the integration is and the
beauty of these kind of analyses that
you can actually make the whole process
completely blinded you don't need to
know what is the protein in the center
of interest you don't need to know what
are the interacting partners and you can
start actually doing analysis in terms
of prioritizing where the next
experiment should go you can have
different thickness of H depending on
how much confidence you might know is on
the given edge high confidence versus
low confidence or multiple pieces of
evidence for interactions for those
proteins you can expand the this first
level of neighbors and then you can
start exploring in the neighborhood of
those interacting partners so we can
find clusters that share the same
neighborhood or you can find individual
proteins that are very different from
the remaining part obviously you can
start adding additional annotation for
example disease if that gene
corresponding genes is overexpressed or
protein within specific disease that
would be the height of the node if it's
another disease it can be the width of
the note so obviously can easily
identify proteins that are relevant to
both diseases or one or the other
disease you can obviously annotate
simply with the gene ontology and you
already have a lot more information to
prioritize where potentially next set of
experiments would go especially if you
know what the phenotype is related to
the protein of interest that you have in
the middle and I'm particularly doing
this kind of analysis with biology's I
find it very useful not to tell them
what the protein is because immediately
they recognize certain names and they
are excited about it if it's fhl 12 604
nobody wants to spend any money and time
doing those experiments yet that might
be the best target to go after the next
level you can obviously add the drugs so
we can identify drugs that target many
of the intro
in partners of the protein of interest
or drugs that are targeting many drugs
they are targeting the same protein and
again the relationship is that from
other literature you may know which
drugs are relevant to a specific disease
so you have all the disease annotation
here now we have another piece of
evidence from completely orthogonal type
of data to tell you that that
potentially is irrelevant piece and
maybe this would be the set of
interactions and set of experiments that
you can start planning in the direction
so one of the kind of follow up examples
is for example recently we were doing
sequencing analysis of lung cancer
samples from Brazilian population and
identified differential micrornas some
of them were novel some of them were
already reported in literature in lung
cancer so we can start debating is it
because this is the first cohort from
Brazilian population if there is some
specific micrornas related to this
population but then you can link them to
transcriptional factors that what
actually are regulated by those
micrornas or other prognostic genes in
lung cancer that are potentially
regulated by these microRNAs through
simple network analysis you can identify
those that are targeted by many of those
differential micro RNAs that are
overexpressed and thus very easily
through integrating these multiple
pieces of information from different
resources you can highlight which genes
potentially are worthwhile validating in
this specific experiment what is really
neat is that you can take those genes
then and take yet another orthogonal
data protein interactions and basically
linked them through physical protein
interactions now the reason why it's
interesting that we started with micro
RNAs we predicted micronet to gene
targets annotated with transcriptional
at virgin ontology and prognostic and
differential genes in lung cancer and
then to guad came out of it put it into
the network of protein interactions and
then you can actually do a simple
statistical enrichment of our refining
and Richmond in this network now for the
proteins that are known to be prognostic
so there is noise in all of the data
there are missing pieces in all of the
data when once you start finding
significant with the proper obviously
controls and false discovery rate
controls that shows that there must be
some biologically and clinically role
and signal that you can follow up on
there were also discussions about which
interactions are good or bad or which
high-throughput assays is good or bad I
like this this network figure also for
the fact not only there is nice and
colorful green blossoming but also when
you look into all of the different
colors of the edges are different
methods biological assets that were used
for detecting these interactions for
these two melatonin receptors and you
don't need to kind of analyze it in any
specific way but you see that there is a
lot of heterogeneity if you would use
just one of the methods you have small
fraction of the interactome that is
there so it's really multitude of
methods that you have to integrate you
know to have a better sense of what
these receptors or how they are
interacting and one of the reasons that
was pulled out in a paper is for example
do identifying the mechanism the thick
edges are from from the paper
interactions that were detected through
these methods so it's only through this
new interaction that you can explain
some of the mechanism that was already
in postulated in the literature but
there was no direct link between these
receptors and bolton voltage-gated
calcium channel so again by integrating
different kinds of assets is the only
way how you could explain some of the
known biology so one of the aspects is
that when we are doing this kind of
integration we usually have semi the
biological or clinical reason to do
those integrations and they will drive
our interests in integrating the data
and possibly validation but we need to
study relevant biology we cannot study
just what is significant we always need
to kind of keep track of does it make
sense can we do in vitro functional
assays that will prove it or not and one
of the aspects is that if you take for
example prognostic jeans you can map
them to the network and start
studying what processes they are
involving what are the connections
between the milk and undefined on the
networks and to really highlight the
aspect of data does matter more than the
approach is if you take just one of the
data sets not integrated data you have
significantly more sparse network you
may apply any kind of sophisticated
graph theory algorithm you get
completely different results from these
two networks and in one you cannot
really start planning any follow up
experiments in the other one you may
start planning experiment there is
possibility that some of these edges are
wrong but you have the reason and also
the context of how to validate them
where to validate in what sells and what
the there are different assets that you
can also apply once you have an edge as
opposed to when you are searching for
possible edges obviously eventually we
will start to or BR or this starting to
have another problem that almost
everything will be connected to almost
anything or the density of this network
is going to be larger and larger and we
have to be careful there were already
examples about ubc human network now
it's about 800,000 edges and 18,000
proteins I will have some example on it
but also what you can do with it so what
aspect is the obviously UBC and p53 was
already discussed should we remove it
because it's connected to everything or
should we consider it but then it will
be showing up in almost any analysis so
scalability of the algorithm is
definitely one aspect if you want to
visualize it analyzed it run these
algorithms but also then quality of the
data and annotation of these nodes and
edges that will enable you to filter out
in an in and out what is relevant and
what is not so I will go through this
faster again it's kind of continuing
motivation is that we really have to
integrate multiple hybrid methods not
only the different biological assays but
also computational methods that will
help us enhance what we can learn from
this network how can we analyze them to
the disease related or biology related
context so several papers now
this is the new interaction databases I
was mentioning almost 18,000 proteins
and a little bit over 800,000 edges but
the big chunk which is the blue are the
predicted interactions it's multiple
methods using in February I was talking
in more detail about it but the papers
go into detail of what information you
can include from sequence from
expression from homology and so on
orthologs or homology based predictions
are relatively small fraction of these
and still even when you integrate what
is known from high-throughput
experiments and from curated literature
is more than other resources now you can
still argue that this chunk is going to
give you a lot of false positives there
is a lot of validation that not
necessarily that's true we basically
were validating with other biological
assays true positives versus false
positive is very comparable to the
biology classes so it's not much worse
it's comparable the other aspect I like
to kind of highlight and this is
relatively limited said that we have
been doing about 200 pairs of
interactions people believe that what is
curated is correct by chance we found
couple of incorrect interactions and
then we started to systematically go
through it and it just shows highlight
of some of the errors the blue ones are
errors the green ones are correctly
curated data obviously different source
of the database have different ratio of
correct and incorrect some have more in
correct and correct one has to be
careful about that but in general it's
showing about fifty percent of errors
even in curated data set so you cannot
say that if it's a curated resource
that's the high confidence interaction
if it is too hybrid is low confidence
those generalizations just don't work
here here so this was this is the yeah
from nature methods couple of years back
and what they had was 92 the kariad of
data analysis that was only 92 positive
pairs 92 true negatives and they were
running five different assays also not
running mass spec and not running other
methods but still basically what is the
sensitivity and was the false discovery
rate for those individual methods and
then we run the prediction algorithm
that was able to control the false
discovery rate and still detected twice
as many interactions and true positives
as the other assays but it's only 92 and
also this obviously is only 200 so would
be interesting to to plow through it in
more systematic way so going back to the
validation really the power is the
integration I mean I showed one example
where you integrate mass spec is to
hybrid mammoth screen different
biological assays and that gives you
much better sensitivity for the screen
in this case we were linking
computational predictions with
biological assay and again it gives you
much more sensitivity and controllable
false discovery obviously the biological
assay also matters which is kind of
interesting that going back to the
comment at the beginning is what is the
ground truth when we make a prediction
the biological experiments and ground
truth but if I give my predict
interactions to be down who is running
his screen at about twenty-five percent
sensitivity well gives me from hundred
interactions giving 25 that doesn't mean
that the rest is incorrect is just
that's the sensitivity of that screen so
it's very useful to also be able to
potentially identify should i give this
interaction to Boston should I these
give these interactions to oly or what
is the method what is the lab what are
the cells in which I have the highest
chance of validating the interaction so
true positive false negatives so going
back to this interaction database
obviously the numbers are interesting
but this is starting to be more and more
useful as I was mentioning that the den
furs are denser and denser where we try
to add
the interactions with different tissues
based on a gene and protein evidence
obviously for some organisms there is
very limited evidence available that we
can integrate at the present time but
for human is relatively well
characterized so what this can give you
is that you can go through the tissue
and identify where those interacting
pairs are detectable or conserved and
you can also then a lot of the cancer
human cancer genes or biology is being
done on a mouse model or on a fly
organism so you can also determine if is
the right model for whatever
interactions are part of the pathway or
complex you are studying and you can I
don't have time to go into much detail
but you can actually identify those
where these interactions are conserved
so not just that you have homology of
the corresponding proteins but that
interaction is likely also existent in a
given tissue so how can you use such
information is still under review sir I
don't want to go into too much detail on
that but suffice to say proteins of
interest you generate a network that
potentially connects them because there
is a lot of interest in this case it's
allowing to brain metastases so what
makes sense is to not consider all of
the interaction but consider
interactions that are like brain or
landgon brain-specific I'm not
interested what potential is in spleen
and prostate and and so on so we can
easily identify what subsidies relevant
to data analyses and what is really cool
again is a call it a validation output
is that sorry let me backtrack here so
those that are highlighted here we
identified as being central in the
network through simple all pair shortest
path analysis of centrality in the
network and nobody's interesting is
actually 18 of the 20 identified through
this method in line gardena carcinoma
our significant hazard ratio and a
significant value and on top of it when
you combine them in a signature in a
regression model on another that we
built on a TCGA data we were able to
validate significance of the left out of
that split of the patients with a
strongly predictive or prognostic value
so
kind of links again information that is
it's a large network it's noisy but the
level of tissue specificity that we can
interject into it has a clinical
implication because we identify proteins
that actually validate it quite nicely
18 out of 20 clinically so another kind
of aspect is that you can not only
integrate obviously gene ontology you
can integrate disease information you
can integrate biological processes where
these proteins are interacting so again
work with eager stragglers group
identifying individual novel
interactions and then characterizing
them in terms of where the links are
more than you would expect by random
chance that those multiple interacting
proteins are involved in the same
disease they are involved in the same
process there's a similar biological
function and in a sense in which for
that which on the next level you can
link information from what we know about
drug targets and also what we know about
transcriptionally regulated genes as a
result of application of the drug
because all of those genes that we know
for a given drug are changed
transcriptionally as after application
of the drug through the novel
interaction we can actually now link
them because obviously if drug targets
this protein and these genes change
there must be some path that goes in
between them so again this kind of
highlights that those new interactions
are the way are the bridges or tunnels
or whatever you all call them roads that
help you link what we know is changing
on what we know is a drug target so now
kind of interesting aspect what we
wanted to see is that is there more
information in a sense in these networks
and it has been described here and also
in similar kind of meetings that you
take expression data and it can generate
coexpression graph based on differential
expression across two conditions in this
case normal lung and lung cancer Wow as
Natasha many years actually scarily over
a decade ago introduced the approach
with graph alleged analysis what is
intriguing is that then you take take
these large graphs
and in a sense why useful is that this
is just lung cancer you can then apply
to any different cancer any different
disease and a lot of graph comparisons
but you can simply look into the
frequency of individual graph light and
identify which graph leads are more
frequent in a tumor graph versus the
normal graph and what is interesting is
that it seems which is not that
surprising that tumor graph is losing
all of the graphs or many of the graph
leads with cycles so it's routing the
redundancy and also what is interesting
is that long stretches of linear paths
are basically potentially creating
shortcuts for those individual graphs
that are in a sense are connecting maybe
pathways that are normally not connected
so we started to explore it further and
it's definitely true that you are
linking pathways and again it was
discussed earlier what is a pathway
nothing is in nature we kind of
identified as a yes are the positions of
normal grab on did you learn it's normal
samples and tumor samples and from those
you generate the co-expression graphs no
separately and then you identify what is
different and what is similar between
them but it's kind of the first step
obviously there are the caveat with this
approach it's almost the same as when we
had we've been the hot night right it's
not that this is wrong but there's a
version two that is coming because one
of the aspect is that this is looking at
the co-expression and it doesn't mean
that those are corresponding to protein
interactions so it's interesting you can
find these differences but the next step
was to see how does it overlap with
known or predicted protein interactions
that step makes sense kind of only after
the protein interaction network is
relatively large otherwise you'd get too
many false negatives so the next step is
to see if would be identifies
potentially disrupted can we apply this
call it a mathematical approach and see
if we can repair them
network most of the drug prediction
algorithms basically work to identify
individual nodes and try to change the
expression of the notes that's fine but
now we actually want to change the whole
network so the optimization process then
we has to go into identifying what do we
know about the node in terms of the data
that we analyzed and also data in this
case across large number of lung cancer
data sets how is upregulated or
downregulated significantly and also
what do we know about the edge meaning
that we have two nodes linked are they
correlated positively or negatively or
not correlated at all when we are
considering the normal and cancer set
and we also add the additional
information that do we have any evidence
that those corresponding proteins are
interacting pair at least predicted to
interact and so we are obviously trying
to identify what is biologically
meaningful and dust we want potentially
true physical protein interactions not
just coexpression but Jessica expression
is also useful because we know we don't
know all of the protein interactions so
then the optimization on the drag level
is that not only we want to find what is
the most most interesting sub graph
based on these waiting but also we want
to find a minimal number of drugs that
will maximally change the graph as we
want both on the nodes and edges what is
then basically the step is then you can
you can really find the optimal settings
oh ha what what drugs what combination
of drugs where do they apply and what
should they change and you can really
quantitate it based on an impact weight
from which you can vary systematically
pick up combination of drugs that would
be working for the sub graph and luckily
then in a biological app we can try on
in this case three different lung cancer
cell lines and identify that not only
they change the phenotype of the slice
but also the drug combination work
better than single drugs individually
and in most of the cases that we tested
in all of these three different cell
lines now what is also interesting is
that you can go mechanistically back to
this graph
and identify did we change the note and
did we change the pairs of the notes so
in essence did we repair the network as
a result and in most of the cases we
actually did change majority of the sub
network of interest obviously limited in
vitro validation but at least it kind of
points into the aspect that we might be
able to start rewiring the networks and
make them more similar I mean take the
lung cancer network and make it more
similar to normal lung network and
that's potentially ha I have some
driving to the cure because you are not
only considering that I mean the
traditional approach of drug
repositioning is that you change the
expression of the node whereas here we
are looking also in all of the connected
pairs of the nodes how are we changing
the other node because drag might be
target or transcriptionally changing
this node but it's linked to this node
and it's changing as well so we have to
consider are they changing in the same
direction opposite direction you may fix
one but you may screw up the other so we
had to consider all of those nodes
together as a group as a signature in a
sense just Rock the one known then the
most you're changing is one or two edges
but what's the model under
I don't understand how do you predict
all the drug's effects so that comes in
the earlier that's a good point i don't
hear so through other data we know what
are the drug target so you can map drug
targets to the nodes within this network
or we can map drag that we know
transcriptionally modify corresponding
genes and so based on those two pieces
of information you overlay on the
network and identify what do you need to
change
um so
I will try to go faster ha I don't know
how many people follow dr. house one of
the thing that is kind of intriguing is
the experimentation he does he doesn't
in a sense comply with the regulations
and so on but from the diagnostic new
point makes more sense because you had
to perturb the system you know that you
understand what potentially is wrong but
the other aspect that kind of comes from
the series is that everybody lies I mean
all of the patients lie and kind of the
motivation for it is that will in a lot
of the clinical work or clinically
related work again ground truth we take
the literature published literature as a
ground truth and unfortunately a lot of
it is actually false and you may say
well what is locked so few years back we
were doing analysis in terms of how many
papers are retracted and there is
exponentially I mean there is a
exponential increase of retractions even
when you consider how many more papers
are published every year if you take the
titles of those papers are strikingly
there is a lot of clinical and biology
and patient related studies that are
being retracted so we repeated the
analyses in December and I mean there is
little drop but it's still highly
exponential increase in number of
retracted papers still the same kind of
aspect when you look into the titles or
journals there is a lot of clinical
relevant generals that are being
retracted our papers that are being
retracted and when you consider is the
five percent that's relatively large
number so there were other studies this
is few years back now and what is
interesting is kind of two aspect that
kind of come from it it's already bad
that these papers are retracted but
there is a large fraction of fraudulent
or explorer or suspected fraudulent
papers there is only less than
twenty-five percent of mistakes I mean
less than twenty-five percent is still
large but wasn't in twenty-five percent
mistake what is worse though that if
there are errors people carried in about
twenty six months in average if it's
fraudulent it takes almost twice as long
and that's striking I mean you have
smart people whom I
who fabricate the data or change the
experiment and it takes a long time I
mean as a community to find the server
this is not our data somebody else need
these kind of analysis but that shows
you that you cannot trust everything
that you read you cannot trust all of
the curated interactions either and so
on so you kind of finalized I hope I
convinced you that diversity is
necessary we have to have multiple
methods computational and biological
assets because only through those we
will be able to explore wider range of
clinical and biological phenomena
putting together biological and
computational assay obviously makes
faster is cheaper and more relevant
predictions and validations of the
experiments there are many aspects that
we don't know yet and we have to be
open-minded we cannot have biases that
this should be like this many times we
would be wrong and I don't have time at
all to go into this but there is some
cool data that we now have where people
are focusing again on on drug
repositioning treatment of cancer and so
on or other diseases and there is a lot
of stuff from what we eat and what we do
that affects it probably been stronger
so with that thanks to all of the
different collaborators across different
diseases and funding agencies other lab
members did I didn't mention before and
if people are interested these tools are
publicly available thank you
so the analysis of networking tumor and
normal but you thought about the issue
heterogeneity at my gen 18 I mean if we
be analyzed it across multiple different
or I mean that the training data was
multiple data sets and we validated on
multiple validation data sets when you
see the same patron across different
cohorts the diminish is the potential
problem that there would be
heterogeneity to play a significant role
geez yes of general dysregulation know
that
oh it does because you would you would
not see anything I mean there will be
multiple heterogeneities that will be
present and very unlikely you will get
the same co-expression differences
between the normal and different
heterogeneous subpopulations but to
answer the other kind of part of the
question is that or the aspect is that
yes you can do this kind of analysis not
only on cancer type basis you can do
different different histological
subtypes and we did actually even
analysis of for example in lung cancer
context of care a specific mutation
adenocarcinoma so you can definitely
zoom in on a much more pure
subpopulations but usually what that
means is that you have much smaller
number of samples so again one of the
aspects of larger scale analysis you
have larger samples you have more power
but some some differences in terms of
the cohorts or heterogeneity you zoom in
on a more pure population but you have
smaller number of samples and you might
not have enough for the independent
validation
so maybe we'll take additional questions
break and thank you again